quantum learning platform. In this tutorial, what you might notice is that we have created a series of helper
functions early in the notebook that we can call upon later to make our lives a little easier. I want to mention these
now, not because it's part of the official or formal process, but because this is often what experimentalists do
in real life to help them run these types of experiments. And it also shows us how we are going to break down our
problem even further. The functions we define in the notebook are as follows. Remove cubit couplings.
Define cubit couplings. Construct the layer couplings. Construct entangling layers. And lastly, define trotterized
circuit. Next, let's talk about layer couplings, which help define how cubits
interact with their neighbors during the simulation. Our quantum devices use something called the heavy hexagonal
layout. A special pattern for connecting cubits. In this layout, we can group the connections called edges into three
separate sets where no two connections in the same set share a cubit. This is
important because on a real quantum computer, we can't run two cubit gates at the same time if they involve the
same cubit. Each cubit can only be involved in one gate at a time. By
dividing all the connections into three layers, we can apply two cubit gates across the entire device in three
rounds, making sure no cubit is used in more than one gate per layer. These
gates implement the ZZ interaction from the Ising model, and they're repeated at each step of the simulation called the
trotder step. twirling modifies the noise in the device so that even a simple noise model
is likely to be accurate. This also makes it possible to accurately learn the noise model and use the obtained
information and error mitigation techniques.
Next, we have to remove our bad cubits from our possible list of physical cubits that we can use for the
experiment. Like I said, a cubit can become bad for a variety of different reasons. Sometimes it's just a bad
calibration, a simple mistake that can be resolved by just calibrating again.
Sometimes it's a bit more complicated and related to something that we call a TLS, which is a two-level interfacial
defect that leads to cubit parameter fluctuations and relaxation. This can be
resolved by warming up the whole system a bit and then cooling it back down. But that takes a while and isn't possible to
do over the cloud. So for now, the easiest thing to do is just exclude them from our list of possible physical
cubits that we'll use. You can identify which cubits are not behaving expected easily from the IBM quantum platform.
You can plot the cubit characteristics there in the platform or download them as a CSV. Then create a list of all the
cubits that you want to exclude and simply remove them from the list of total physical cubits on the device.
All right. Now let's continue on with our mapping step generating our troterized circuit. Now as we showed
earlier trotterization discretizes the time evolution into a series of steps and we need to decide how many steps.
We'll choose six here. But in general the strategy is to balance something called the troder error which is an
algorithmic approximation error with the error arising from decoherence. More troder steps reduces the approximation
error but require deeper quantum circuits which experience more decoherence noise. We will define the
circuit in terms of the theta parameter which is the strength of the external magnetic field layer couplings and the
number of steps and cubits and of course the device back end. Because of the
dependence of the magnetization of the system on the strength of the external magnetic field, it is interesting to
execute the simulation at various values of the magnetic field strength which translate into different angles of RX on
the rotation for RX in the circuit. Now with having generated our circuit, we'll move on to its optimization.
First step here is to define a path manager. Remember in the context of the Qiskit SDK, transpolation refers to the
process of transforming an input circuit into a form that is suitable for execution on a quantum device.
Transpolation typically occurs in a sequence of steps called transpiler passes. A pass manager is an object that
stores a list of transpiler passes and can execute them on a circuit. create a pass manager by initializing a pass
manager object with a list of transpiler passes. In the end, our pass manager
will create an ISA circuit, a circuit that must be written in terms of the backend's instruction set architecture,
which describe the circuit and gates which are native to the backend but lack the timing information needed to run the
circuit. Now we are ready to execute our circuit which is step three of kiskuit patterns. Now as stated before we will
definitely be using the estimator here as our primitive of choice for this experiment since we want to measure the
total magnetization of the system and estimating the expectation value of the observables is what the estimator was
designed for. In this step it will also be crucial to specify our options for error mitigation. We will use zero noise
extrapolation to get the best results possible. Particularly in the tutorial, you will see that we specify two or more
noise factor values at which to evaluate the extrapolated models and specify
probabilistic error amplification as our amplification option. Now, probabilistic
error amplification or PA was really the error mitigation technique method of choice here because it scales so much
better than the other options. And that's what's important when we're working at the level of 100 plus cubits.
Last but not least, run the experiment and it will take some time to complete, but for now, let's reference the data
cued and stored from the tutorial. We will examine the metadata making particular note of the layered gates and
the mitigated layers since we are about to use those to remove a bunch of errors from our raw data. We are almost ready
to plot our final results. But before we do that, let's quickly add an interlude here on what exactly is meant by zero
noise extrapolation or zene. We've covered it briefly in earlier episodes, but to review, zero noise extrapolation
is an error mitigation technique that removes the effects of an unknown noise during circuit execution that can be
scaled in a known way. It assumes expectation values scale with the noise by a known function shown here where the